nora tschirner mit der großen weichte
nicht ganz ernst nehmen auf clixoom sie
beschimpft nämlich ihren freund warum
das so ist und wie es kommt dass jetzt
im talk und natürlich spricht sie über
den neuen disney pixar film merida wo
sie ja die hauptrolle sind krohn spricht
also viel spaß dabei und ansonsten bis
dann blättern
ließ die lage die lage ist schon finde
ich relativ amtlich
bisschen abgehoben
naja ich bin ja berlin ja die war sicher
schon auch mal im kino wird dass man
hier so während alle um welchen
vorstellungen sind man so sitzt schön
ist schöne tisch hinaus gedacht aber wir
haben uns extra aufgebaut und das ist
auch das ganze haus fertigt er habe das
haus auch aufgehört hat und jetzt haben
wir die kulissen
also ich hätte aber synchronisieren ist
nicht ganz so aufwendig oder nee das
geht ja nur eine woche ist dann sehr
sehr konzentriert also man das amt schon
echt platt aber
es hat echt was macht mehr spaß als
drehen
für stelle ich jetzt wieder sein und
nicht personen reden
also auf dauer will ich jetzt sagen
nicht es macht total viel spaß und es
macht für die zeit genau so viel spaß
wie drehen aber es ist ja also es fehlt
ja ein ganz entscheidender teil also
dieses diese erarbeitung der ganzen
sache wo ich ja auch ganz gern
eigentlich dabei wollen die ist ja schon
abgeschlossen also niemand ist nicht
mehr nötig wie mich ist nicht glücklich
aber auch überhaupt sowie gebieten szene
in tonfall und sowas das haben wir alles
sozusagen mit dem regisseur und den
hauptdarstellern dort sozusagen schon
geklärt und insofern kommt das bei mir
fertig andere ich übernehmen das und
denke mir ja das macht natürlich sinn
wird ihr euch schon überlegt hatte
emotional geschah hat auch mal so machen
aber dieses finden einer szene und des
charakters ein bisschen weg aber ist das
dann nicht auch noch wahnsinnig
schwierig das zu machen weil man ja
wirklich gut und ich stelle mir vor dass
ist ja so eine spur die man dann auch
beschreiben muss man kann ja nicht nach
rechts oder links man kann nicht traurig
sein wenn es lustig ist und das stimmt
wir ein bisschen auf die feininger ist
ja doch man ist diese figur und zwar man
kann sie nicht mehr interpretieren oder
nicht mehr los naja aber das lustige
finde ich eigentlich ich habe dort
manchmal zu mir gesagt dass die jungen
anderer toller regisseur gesagt hätte
dass der hund von seiner tennis
trainerin das auf das okay so kommst aus
aber das eigentlich guter schauspieler
man weiß nie was als nächstes macht es
gibt eigentlich nur einen weg und die
figur ist auch für meine figur arbeitet
ist so
es gibt eine gewisse folgerichtigkeit
innerhalb der sache und deswegen ist das
jetzt nicht eine mega einschränkung es
macht eigentlich alles sind so und das
haben die hre nur herausgefunden schon
vor mir sozusagen also es ist auch ein
bisschen wie ein rätsel natürlich kann
unterschiedliche schauspieler kommt so
kommen dann trotzdem unterschiedliche
sachen raus aber eigentlich ist ein
charakter in sich stimmig und ist ein
bisschen wie so mega sudoku also du
musst wenn der da so ist musst du da und
so habe ich jetzt erstmals zusammen
die forschung nach auch wenn das jetzt
so doku ist wie lange brauchst du um das
zu lösen also wieso tags brauchst du um
eine sales tax meistens eben zb
eigentlich nicht weil diese haben diese
arbeit du musst ja das ganze ding lösen
also sonst kannst du fühlst dich dann
nur eine sekunde aber dann werde zum
schluss hat so druck und trotzdem fällt
also es ist ja der punkt du musst
eigentlichen ganzen bogen vorher aber es
gibt trotzdem die es gibt die teile
genau die sind ja aber sozusagen schon
bei dem synchron dinge sind die ja schon
also wie viel text brauche ich da ist
sind auf jeden fall
nicht so viele weil ich wir haben das
sudoku für mich ja schon lösung beim
drehen ist es im besten fall auch so das
bild das ich einfach weiß wo ich hin
will und was funktioniert weil ich
vorher schon in bogen weiß und da ich
weiß die bestimmte sachen gehen gar
nicht mehr aber was drehen gibt
es noch kollegen drehen gezwungen auch
die ganze vorarbeit die proben meinem
buch erarbeitung dass darüber reden über
das buch gucken was schon zwar stimmt
also proben finde ich zum beispiel sehr
sehr wichtig brücken nicht so viel
gemacht und deutschland
ja ich weiß nicht warum man sich macht
aber ich sehe man sieht ja die
ergebnisse manchmal
weh aber ich find's schön endlich ein
bisschen erstaunlich muss ich sagen weil
es gibt schon auch regisseure die proben
aber wenn ich merke dass man wenn ich im
ausland re ist das völlig normal dass
man probt eine woche und für mich macht
das überhaupt gar keinen sinn auch als
regisseur ich will dass du dann heißt es
man wolle keine zeit wo ich so denke ich
kenne also meine kollegen würden alle
sofort sagen für proben immer zeit und
wollen auch kein geld wird natürlich für
weil das ist ja nur sein erlebnis und
wenn man eine geschichte erzählt und das
ist für mich eigentlich der punkt wo die
wo man merkt ob das funktioniert am
geschichte erzählen ist findet proben
statt und ich wundere mich dann immer
dass kinder nachts nächste denke das war
gewagt und dann stellen sich beim
schnitt fest so
was nicht was nicht an manche sachen
findet man wirklich raus erst wenn man
spielt und wenn man es sehen bestimmte
sachen funktionieren auf dem papier und
funktionieren dann nicht mehr was ist
dann der unterschied wände mit probe und
ohne prothese
also ist immerhin stellt sich das ja
immer vor die die kleinen trittin stellt
sich vor die typische szene beim set
wenn der regisseur nicht weiß was er
will sagt beat mal was an ja das ist
glaube ich schon auch so als ob wir
finden auch gut dass man das anhört weil
ich letztendlich im besten falle hier
schon die personen die die figur am
besten kennt und insofern weiß ich auch
was ich dort anbieten kann aber im und
mit proben und probt am set schon aber
dieses vorab proben dass man die szenen
oder das ganze buch durchgeht und guckt
wie stehen die ihm zu einander und so
für eine familienaufstellung teilweise
das ist eben was was sonst fehlt aber am
set klar biete ich was an und meistens
funktioniert dann auch wenn ich meine
arbeit gut gemacht habe und dann kann
man immer noch da gibt es immer noch
total viele facetten wie viele wege gibt
also um mal zu deinem eingeschränkten da
zurück zu kommen da gibt es immer noch
mannigfaltige möglichkeiten du hast ja
auch als dein eigener charakter nieder
sekunden tausend möglichkeiten aber in
deinem kosmos werden trotzdem
wahrscheinlich auf 23 beschränkt sein
und eben nicht auf eine milliarde oder
so man ist aber oft nicht bewusst aber
es gibt trotzdem in seinem handeln eine
bestimmte folgerichtigkeit außerdem ist
ein psychopath 8
da ist das glaube ich dafür gibt es
teilweise richtig keit aber in einer
anderen welt so toll ist wenn du jetzt
sagt das ist wie eine familie
ausstellung aufstellung geht er das nahe
manchmal oder
mir geht es muss es eigentlich nadine
aber jetzt nicht so ordnen wohne ich
auch da kann ich gar nicht mehr aufhören
unter der brücke zu wohnen ich weiß gar
nicht mehr wer ich bin oder so aber wenn
du richtig wenn das funktioniert bist du
total drin und muss ich da jetzt auch
nicht unbedingt verlieren aber wenn zum
beispiel die szene total gut
funktioniert verabschiede mich in dem
moment wo die szene läuft von mir selber
und dann jetzt vom bitte bis zum danke
passiert was anderes als dann kann ich
auch wirklich kommt ist jetzt ein
bisschen ski zum aber dann kann ich zum
beispiel schon vom mit einem mit
jemanden mit dem ich total professionell
zusammenarbeiten wo ich wirklich privat
nullinger interesse an dem haben als
diese figur mich in dessen figur
verliebt in anderthalb minuten und
danach ist auch viel aber es ist
trotzdem so ein hut ist es so ein kosmos
war sondern argument ist man kann sich
darin verlieren passiert das manchmal
man kann sich darunter aber ich meine
jetzt nicht im sinne von und dann komme
ich nach hause und das ist hier immer
noch meine katze und es gibt sogar an es
gibt ja leute ja ich bin nicht ich finde
das kann sie ja gerne sein und ein paar
sachen färben manchmal auch ab ich sage
dass wir immer im hamburger
schauspielhaus trainspotting geprobt
haben acht wochen und wir so viele
schimpfwörter in diesem stück hatten und
auch ständig mit improvisation dass mein
damaliger freund irgendwann gefragt hat
ob es jetzt okay wäre wenn ich einmal
widerspreche also würde ich nicht
irgendwie mit wölfen normalerweise nur
mich umgeben oder so schlimm dass das
ein bisschen abwerten und so ein
bisschen bestimmter tonfall von einer
gruppe auf unserem setup herb aber dass
ich jetzt nicht mehr meine identität
sortieren kann nach drehschluss das ist
nicht so aber das gibt es sicher nicht
auch bei leuten das ist aber nicht meine
absicht ich habe das sind glaube ich so
sachen die wenn wenn man der nähe der
louis zuguckt oder so und der einfach
ich hab das funktioniert nur so und ich
habe einen riesenrespekt vor ist aber
nicht mein weg zu arbeiten unbedingt
resort wo ich habe das mit den
schimpfwörtern was du erzählst eine
beziehung habe ich jetzt von anderen
youtube angehört kaum gelohnt haben
gesagt das wäre gut für die beziehung
wenn man sich ordentlich geschimpft
okay aber dann macht man es nicht mehr
schlimmer wenn man sich dann streitet
wird auch nicht schlimmer es wird schon
sagt gehört ist dann aber die hat gibt
branchen das ist eine gefühlte zahlen
mal probieren wir allemal autopista maus
noch einmal vergeben nach stelle ja
jetzt nochmals um rita wenn du sagst das
war schon im korsett war sagt dass dna
diese rolle oder
total super schöner nicht hätte ich muss
das so
war das auch bei dir im elternhaus ihr
wollt nicht verheiratet und hat gesagt
ja ich es wollte und ich wollte musste
mich da mal frei spielen die aber das
ist übrigens auch gerade wir sowie
dessen die pigs erarbeitet das sind
halten habe ich schon echt das sind ein
paar das sind ein paar kandidaten also
das ist eben kein wunder dass diese
filme so gut werden sowie die arbeiten
was sagen haben den film so besonders
was ist das schwerste der ist es die
geschichte ist erstmal ich glaube an
einen geschichten von den
dänen ist gemein ist es gute geschichten
sind und wie das entsteht ist glaube ich
zu begründen mit der arbeitsweise von
pixar ich kann jetzt natürlich auch
aufzählen was eigentlich film das
besondere ist und so der ist
toll und man ist super man fühlt sich
sogar waren verbunden dieser familie von
ihr mit all jenen komischen die mutter
wird mal ein bisschen kontrollfreak
mäßig und so was wie eine trotzdem sehr
sehr warme familie ist es lustig und es
ist technisch natürlich der hammer die
ms ja selbst wieder vollkommen überholt
und so aber man muss ich trotzdem fragt
woher kommt sowas auch und das ist halt
spannend ich es ist jetzt so dass die
bei pixel hd engine wie so ein eigenes
kleines künstlerdorf da gebaut und das
wird die kreativität und muße wird so
geschützt und steht so oben der film
hatte sechs jahre in entstehung gedauert
und es gibt mehrere punkte wo die gesagt
haben wir fangen ganz von vorne an oder
ist nicht so dass sie sich diese zeit
neben zu sagen wir bringt erst raus wenn
wir es richtig gut fühlen sich keinem
druck beugen das hat auch noch nie
gemacht haben da kann man jetzt wieder
etablieren die können sich auch leisten
muss ich denke ja hier könnte es aber
auch nur leisten weil sie dieses sieht
für diese viele kohle verdient haben
weil sie da hat schon immer so gemacht
haben und konsequent damit waren und
deswegen könnte ich dir noch allen ab
werk der welt bald das ist wahnsinn wie
ich das durchziehen und zwar muss
überlegen aber trotzdem ständig druck
von aussen theoretisch jeder könnte
sagen das muss der nächste film auch gut
finde und nach kommt schneller und so
weiß und dass ich etwas sagen so worm
wir machen unser ding kommen wir zu den
film dabei rauskommt so ist manchmal wie
in deutschland
ich vermisse es immer wenn es mir einem
set nicht passiert in deutschland
passiert es mir am wenigsten tatsächlich
ja also es ist wie es ist ein problem
finde ich ja das ist nicht ich habe
neulich gehört dass die das kind sich
das spannend als die
deutschen film arbeiter von den
ausländischen produktionen die hier
drehen also gerade von den amis gerne
mal als white mexikos bezeichnet werden
weil die so viel arbeiten und so willig
sind
das ist doch so dann kann ich mir
vorstellen dass der mexikaner an sich
schon noch wenig es ein bisschen besser
weißt wie man auch noch leben kann
parallel als der deutsche das ist schon
krass was hier so teilweise
ähnlich so musste voll abgeht und damit
meine ich jetzt nicht viel arbeit
innerhalb bestimmter und sonst hängen
wenn du so rum sondern wenn gearbeitet
wird wird ja richtig gearbeitet und so
und da hat das habe ich im ausland bis
jetzt immer viel besser erlebt hier ist
viel
sagend ewig lange drehtage hier so ja
nie auf alle sind aber der meinung wir
müssen alle mitmachen checken aber nicht
als mensch einfach nicht nach zwölf
stunden arbeiten besser wird ist einfach
so nur nach spanien kommst da ist der
drehtag zehn stunden was übrigens ja
immer noch auch jetzt nicht total wenig
und so wenn du die an kurze frau saß wie
so machten wir treten ja nur so kurz
fragen ob du also die verstehen frage
kann ich sagen wir sollen wir denn sonst
noch leben und ich glaube schon dass das
im langen bogen besser gedacht ist und
das ist in england so und das in
frankreich so also dieses hamsterrad
schleicht sich auch manchmal hier in die
filmindustrie ein und beide sets ist das
zum beispiel nicht so das ist spannend
ja das ist echt wahnsinn und was dann
dabei ich finds halt gar nicht studiert
bereitet es persönlich eine große
genugtuung zu sehen was dann per
vollgelaufen weißt du denke
meine theorie doch ich hab ich glaube
dass das nicht ein zu verlassen also
heute schon auf dem nächsten film ich
freue mich nach dem nächsten titel mehr
und auch vor allem auf die nächste
zusammenarbeit weil das ist echt ein
arbeitet total viel und man hat trotzdem
hinter das gefühl man könnte jetzt noch
zwei jahre so weiter drehen dann hoffe
ich dass er bald kommt es erst oder hat
das drehbuch vorgelegen ich habe
zufällig auf einem mikrochip ich habe es
noch nicht
und noch mehr talk gibt es bei pixum
unter anderem mit sap crm reloaded die
darüber sprechen dass man schlechter als
sie nicht produzieren kann wie dann so
gute videos rauskommen im talk wird es
geklärt oder auch darum die erzählt dass
sie politikerin werden sollte wie das
gekommen ist sein vater im talk mit ihr
also entscheidet euch das oder was und
ansonsten wie war das nochmal genau bis
dann weiter